foreign
[Applause]
year relationship with Shakira it's been
quite a journey nearly a year after the
two broke things off
it all unfolds in a new interview with
Spain's El Pais at first the Soccer Star
brushes off questions about the breakup
telling the reporter I don't want to
talk about it that's when he brings up
his sons with Shakira too many
challenges at the same time they share
10 year old Milan and eight-year-old
Sasha quote everyone has their
responsibility to do what's best for
their kids He suggests he kept quiet for
the sake of the boys it's about
protecting them that's what I'm focused
on and that's my role as a father
everything else is is is is secondary
and in a way
Gerard went Instagram official with his
girlfriend Clara Chia Marty in January
and he sort of addresses the backlash
she's received since including this
so-called diss track from his ex
[Music]
yeah Shakira seemingly calls out Gerard
and Clara in the song
[Music]
in 22 that's seemingly how old Clara was
when she and Gerard got together
Gerard admits to not liking how the
Press has spun the narrative quote the
problem is how people perceive things
essentially says he wants to avoid
becoming clickbait but adds I'm still
doing what I want I'm not gonna waste
money on cleaning up my image
he goes on to make it clear that he's
placing his energy on the people who are
close to him saying he's very happy
there's been changes in my life and I've
known how to preserve that happiness I'm
gonna feel like we have to recite vows
in front of people and formalize it in
order to you know to be together really
I don't believe in that Shakira and
Gerard who never married announced the
end of their long-term partnership last
June fast forward to February
and Shakira told a Mexican TV network in
Moss when a woman has to face the
attacks of life she comes out stronger
she describes the whole ordeal as a
broken dream adding quote you have to
pick up the little pieces from the
ground and put yourself together again
and she echoed what Gerard is saying now
promising to be an example to their
children they really take everything
from you you know I I give them all I
give him not only my physical energy but
also my my my intellectual energy and
you know it's like mothers are always
thinking and
double guessing and and wondering if
we're doing things right or not you know
[Music]
foreign